Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Es ist Zeit für die Ligatour. Wir blicken auf die Männer-Ligen in Frankreich, in Italien, Spanien und England. Jetzt hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass 260. Hallo und herzlich Willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt zur Ligatour. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social. Und ich freue mich sehr, heute wieder die Legendenrunde hier zu begrüßen. Zum einen Marius Seuke von Serie Amore unter anderem. Hallo Marius.
Grüß dich.
Dann ist Fabian Pacolat hier. Fabian, hallo, schön, dass du hier bist. Genau, man kann dir als Ed Rosengartler folgen. Und außerdem wieder hier vom Kicker. Ich freue mich sehr. Michael Postel. Hallo Michi.
Max, grüß dich. Dankeschön.
Sehr schön, dass ihr drei hier seid. Später wird noch Uli Hebel dazustoßen. Der konnte es nicht live einrichten. Dann nehmen wir dann ein Extra-Segment auf. Das hört ihr am Ende dieser Ligatur. Vorher blicken wir auf die Ligen. Aber ich muss natürlich auch noch loswerden. Der Rasenfunk ist werbepaywall und sponsorenfrei. Die Gästehonorare unserer Gäste und alles andere, was dieser Rasenfunk so kostet, das finanzieren wir ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Gerade ist wieder die Podigy-Rechnung gekommen. Also das zahlen wir dann auch. Und rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club könnt ihr erfahren, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt. Schon kleine Beträge helfen, also auch 2 Euro, 3 Euro im Monat. Das summiert sich dann auf, das machen einige so. Bitte tut das auch. Wir lassen euch durch das fehlende Paywall-Konzept so ein bisschen davon kommen, diejenigen, die einfach zu bequem sind, da einen Dauerauftrag einzurichten, weil wir darauf setzen, dass es dann doch genug von euch machen. Und es wäre toll, wenn ihr vielleicht diesen Hinweis hier als Aufwand nehmt, auch wenn ihr nicht alles vom Rasenfunk hört. Gerade sowas wie die Ligatour ist ja ein bunter Vogel in unserer Sendereihe und der erscheint jetzt auch so regelmäßig, dass ihr da vielleicht darüber nachdenken könnt, ob euch das vielleicht schon reicht. Man nennt das das Value for Value Prinzip. Überlegt einfach, was ist euch der Rasenfunk im Monat wert? Einen kleinen Kaffee, einen Kinobesuch. Manche Leute sagen sogar ungefähr Netflix. Also die Bandbreite ist da sehr groß bei unseren Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützerinnen. Danke an alle, die das schon mal getan haben, aber jetzt wollen wir mal reingehen in diese Ligatur. Wir haben wieder ganz verschiedene Themen mitgebracht und wir beginnen mal in der Serie A. Denn, Majus, das ist das einzige Thema, was ich schon eingekündigt habe im Rasenfunk. Deswegen bin ich froh, dass du es auch mitgebracht hast. Das hätte mich sonst ein bisschen schlecht dastehen lassen. Wir müssen, wollen, dürfen über Juventus Turin sprechen, die auf einmal Tabellen 3.
Wir haben es schon lange nicht so gut verstanden. Wir haben es schon lange nicht so gut verstanden. Wir haben es schon lange nicht so gut verstanden. Wir haben es schon lange nicht so gut verstanden. Wir haben es schon lange nicht so gut verstanden. Wir haben es schon lange nicht so gut verstanden. Wir haben es schon lange nicht so gut verstanden. Aller verschiedensten Vereinen im In- und Ausland, also das geht von Genoa, CFC in der 2. Liga bis zum FC Barcelona und Manchester City, Transfers gemacht, von teilweise Jugendspielern für sehr, sehr hohe Millionenbeträge, die es bis heute nicht geschafft haben, irgendwie halbwegs im Profifußball anzukommen. Und da hat die Anklage gesagt, ja, das kann ja irgendwie nicht sein, das ist irgendwie ein Mittel, um die Geschäftsberichte besser aussehen zu lassen, um da Kapitalerträge stehen zu haben und so selbst pro Jahr dann eben auf dem Transfermarkt zum Beispiel aktiver sein zu können, was die Verpflichtung von Stars anbelangt. Da sind ja auch sehr teure Spieler in den letzten Jahren gekommen. Vlaović im Januar 2022, das eine Beispiel mit rund 80 Millionen Euro. Und vielleicht durch diese Verkäufe von Jugendspielern teilweise für 10 Millionen Euro, hätte man sich das sonst vielleicht gar nicht leisten können. Da hat dann der italienische Verband gesagt, das geht irgendwie so nicht, wir müssen da irgendwie was machen. Eine Regelung dagegen ist immer noch nicht entschieden worden, weil es eben unklar ist, wie man das so genau in einen Gesetzestext reinpressen kann. Aber naja, erstmal ist Juventus eben zu diesen 15 Punkten Abzug verurteilt worden und hat dagegen natürlich Berufung eingelegt. Da haben sie jetzt erstmal vorerst Recht bekommen. Also die Strafe ist ausgesetzt worden. Sie ist nicht komplett umgekehrt worden. Also es steht noch nicht fest, dass Juve diese 15 Punkte auch behält. Das wird dann tatsächlich erst nach Saisonende final verhandelt werden. Absolut. Also teilweise werden die Vereine gar nicht wissen, in welchem Europa Cup sie dann vielleicht spielen. Juve stand jetzt auf dem Champions League-Platz, stand vorher aber auf dem möglicherweise Conference League-Platz oder eben auf dem siebten, wenn Florenz heute Abend ins Coppa Italia-Finale einzieht und da vielleicht auch den Titel holt, dann würden sie ja in der Europa League spielen. Dann wäre der siebte vielleicht gar nicht dafür berechtigt. Jetzt wissen wir gar nicht so richtig, wie es weitergeht. Obwohl die Meinung schon in die Richtung geht, dass die wahrscheinlich nicht diese Strafe so wieder aussprechen werden.
Aber hilf mir nochmal kurz, was war jetzt der Grund, diese Strafe rückgängig zu machen? Hängt das damit zusammen, dass dieses Modell, was der Juve getan hat, nämlich Spieler hoch zu bewerten, dass das ja nur im Tausch funktioniert? Denn was ja quasi buchrhetorisch da passiert, ist, ich verkaufe einen Spieler und ich kaufe einen Spieler. Und wenn ich den Spieler kaufe für eine übertriebene Ablösesumme, dann kann ich das erstmal als Zuwachs in meine Bilanz reinschreiben. Also jetzt ganz vereinfacht gesprochen, liebe BLWLer, nicht ausrasten. Und dann schreibe ich das über die Vertragslaufzeit ab. Und dann habe ich wieder, bis es auf Null ist. Und das funktioniert ja tatsächlich nur, wenn da auch ein anderer Verein mitspielt. Denn wenn ich jetzt einfach nur jemanden überteuer kaufe, dann ist das mein Problem. Und Juve hat das ja dann mutmaßlich nur deshalb finanzieren können, weil man gleichzeitig auch einen anderen Spieler abgegeben hat an diesen Verein, auch zu einem wahrscheinlich dann erhöhten Marktwert. Ist das der Grund, warum jetzt dann da entschieden wurde, dass es ungerecht ist, dass nur Juve diese Punkte abbezogen bekommen hat? Oder geht es darum, dass der Punkt der Abzug zu drastisch ist? Was ist da quasi die Grundlage?
Die Grundlage ist, dass man laut dem Olympischen Komitee, also die haben Juve Recht gegeben, weil Juve gesagt hat, dass es kein Recht vorliegt, das das verbietet sozusagen. Man hat etwas gemacht, was übrigens natürlich auch alle italienischen Vereine gemacht haben. Juve-Fans haben sich häufig die Frage gestellt, ob die Verantwortlichen, Anjeli und Co. denn mit sich selbst telefoniert haben, als sie diese Transfers ausgehandelt haben, weil ja kein anderer Verein bisher verurteilt worden ist. Jetzt sind zuletzt auch Ermittlungen gegen die Roma, Lazio und Salernitana aufgenommen worden. Aber Napoli zum Beispiel, diesen berühmten Fall mit Viktor Osimen und den drei Jugendspielern plus dem fast 40jährigen griechischen Torwart, die jeweils für 5 Millionen nach Lille abgegeben wurden und dort, glaube ich, nie gespielt haben oder teilweise niemals auch wirklich da gewesen sind, die sind eben freigesprochen worden davon. Deswegen kann ich natürlich verstehen, dass Juve alles daran setzt, diese Strafe nicht zu bekommen. Also eigentlich wahrscheinlich die Frage kann man erst beantworten, wenn wirklich mal final ein Urteil steht.
Okay, also wir sehen, es geht munter hin und her. Noch ganz kurz ein Wort dann zur sportlichen Situation. Also Juve hatte sich ja durch eine lange ungeschlagen Serie oder fast komplett ungeschlagen, war man da erst wieder in die Situation gebracht, dass man mit diesen 15 Punkten jetzt so gut dasteht. Jetzt zuletzt war es allerdings so, dass man dann dreimal verloren hat. Unter anderem jetzt gegen Napoli, in der Coppa Italia, gegen Inter und gegen Lazio vorher auch schon. Allerdings, man steht jetzt eben auf Tabellenplatz 3, hätte noch Anschluss zu Tabellenplatz 2. Und der Theorie nach könnte das ja noch eine tolle Saison werden für Juve. Man steht im Halbfinale gegen Sevilla in der Europa League. Man könnte ins Coppa Italia-Finale einziehen.
Das seit gestern nicht mehr.
Entschuldigung, man hat ja verloren. So schlau ist der Moderator hier. Als wir sportlich zuletzt über Juve gesprochen haben, war es alles ein bisschen kritischer. Das könnte jetzt dann doch eine recht versöhnliche Saison werden, auch wenn es gut an Napoli geht an diesem Wochenende.
Genau, das steht ja quasi fest. Wenn Juve auf einem Champions League-Platz einläuft, wird sich da aus sportlicher Sicht natürlich niemand beschweren. Eigentlich hatte man jetzt vor diesen drei verlorenen Ligaspielen plus dem Rückspiel im Coppa Italia-Haltfinale sah es alles gar nicht so schlecht aus. Da hatte man in der Liga nur gegen die Roma verloren und sonst eigentlich alles gewonnen. Und sich dadurch auch sukzessive von Platz 12 wieder an die europäischen Plätze gerobbt. Und irgendwie hat man so das Gefühl, jetzt ist zwar dieses Urteil nicht vor den Niederlagen gegen Lazio und Sassuolo gekommen, aber dass sie jetzt eben wieder da oben stehen, dass keine Ahnung, ob die Luft raus ist so ein bisschen. Weil auch das Rückspiel gegen Sporting, das 1-1, das war total – also jetzt im Viertelfinal der Europa League – war sehr, sehr unüberzeugend. Und da hat man dann eigentlich wieder diese behäbige Juve-Mannschaft gesehen, die diesen Saisonstart so schlecht gestaltet hat. Und wo dann ja auch lange Zeit schon Max Allegri's Kopf gefordert wurde. Und so spielt Juve jetzt eigentlich gerade wieder. Und das, obwohl bis gestern noch die Chance auf zwei Titel bestand.
Ach, das ist schon irgendwie – wer soll schon die Juve verstehen? Und wer soll all diese Entscheidungen verstehen? Es ist wirklich schwierig.
Dazu kommt noch ein, ein möchte ich noch anbringen, dass jetzt unter der Woche ein Bericht in der Gazette hat, der los Bord stand, dass die UEFA je nachdem, wie das Urteil ausfällt und ob Juve wirklich letztlich auf Platz, also auf den Champions League-Plätzen landet, dass die UEFA alles daran setzen möchte, dass Juve von ihr aus ausgeschlossen wird. Weil eigentlich so ein Ding, was ich mir schon immer gedacht habe, weil die spezielle Beziehung zwischen Andrea Agnelli, dem ehemaligen Juve-Chef und Alexander Schäferin, dem UEFA-Chef, ist ja sein Trauzeuge, glaube ich, gewesen oder Pate seines Kindes oder so. Und die sind ja super zerstritten, seit diese Super League-Geschichte aufgekommen ist. Und dass man da Juve noch gerne eins auswischen würde, das ist irgendwie, von meinem Gefühl her, nicht so weit hergeholt. Da hat natürlich einer aus dem Juve-Board gestern noch gesagt, dass das alles Gerüchte sind. Aber ja, also ich finde das nicht so weit hergeholt, dass die UEFA denen da vielleicht noch eins reindrücken wird.
Ja, und dann geht es vor den Kass und dann sagt der Kass ja im Moment mal… Ja, genau.
Das wird dann 2025 entschieden.
Ja, aber wirklich, genau. Da wird dann nachträglich der Champions-League-Titel wieder zuerkannt. Genau. Ja, bei allem, was ich kritisch finde bei solchen buchhörterischen Tricks und auch Juve gegenüber als Super League mit Begründer und so weiter und so fort, könnte ich ganz viele Dinge zu sagen. Aber es ist halt wirklich komisch, wenn ein Geschäft, das nur funktioniert, wenn beide Seiten mitmachen, dann zumindest jetzt in diesem Fall erst mal nur einem betrifft. Das ist schwierig, das entspricht nicht meinem Rechtsverständnis und da möchte ich mal sehen, wie die UEFA das durchsetzt, aber wir werden es ja da miterleben. Es ist ja schön, dass man als Sportjournalist jetzt immer dann solche Urteile lesen darf und sich da… Ja, ne, das macht richtig Spaß. Aber gut, immerhin hat es mit Marktwerten zu tun, das ist dann noch dein Heimspiel für dich. Okay, also ich danke dir für diesen Überblick. Das war jetzt einmal ein längerer Blog, aber das interessiert das sicherlich auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Dann würde ich mal vorschlagen, gehen wir doch vom drittplatzierten der Serie A zum drittplatzierten der Liga. Da sind wir in Frankreich und wir wollen Michael auf Lens schauen, die mit 66 Punkten auch noch den Anschluss haben an Platz 2. Marseille nur 67 Punkte. Lens hat jetzt zuletzt mal verloren gegen PSG mit 1 zu 3, aber ansonsten läuft das in der jüngeren Vergangenheit sehr, sehr erfolgreich mit fünf Siegen, die man da in den letzten sechs Spielen hatte. Was ist von Lens noch zu erwarten? Können die vielleicht Marseille noch abfangen? Man spielt ja auch noch gegeneinander in zwei Spieltagen.
Richtig. Das ist am sechsten ist das Spiel, 21 Uhr, in Lens, vor dieser Riesenkulisse in Nordfrankreich. Also ich glaube, dass Lens auf jeden Fall das Zeug dazu hat. Auch die Niederlage gegen PSG, die du angesprochen hattest – was war das nach 19 Minuten? Ich glaube, ich habe mir einen Platzverweis kassiert, zu Recht meiner Ansicht nach. Und haben dann das Spiel verloren, haben trotzdem noch Nadelstiche setzen können. Aber da hat man gesehen, wenn Messi und Mbappé dann im Lauf sind, dann hat man einfach keine Chance. Und das ist ja auch nicht so verwerflich. Denn immerhin hat man zuvor gegen die direkte Konkurrenz aus Rennen gewonnen, was ein ganz wichtiger Sieg war, man ist jetzt vor Rennen platziert. Und hat dann auch nachgelegt, hat dann gegen Monaco gespielt. Das war, also den französischen Medien, war dann die Rede von einer Demonstration, von einer Bloßstellung der Monigassen. Und da muss ich auch sagen, es war beeindruckend, wie sie da gespielt haben. So spielen sie allerdings schon die gesamte Saison auf diese Art und Weise. Und zwar geht es bei den Lansoirs ganz viel über die Physis. Also die Rennen unfassbar viel, schaffen es in der 70. Minute noch einen draufzulegen, pressen hoch die ganze Zeit und zwingen so ganz viele Tore. Sie haben mit den schnellen Flügelspielern zwei richtige Waffen und dann natürlich auch einen Vollstrecker vorn drin, mit Louis Openda, der bei 17 Toren steht aktuell, auch ein junger Belgier. Das hängt vieles offenbar damit zusammen, dass im Herbst damals der Leistungsdiagnostiker ging, das war Laurent Bessière, auch sein Kollege Dubois, die nach Nizza gegangen sind. Dann kam Benoit Delaval, der schon unter Marcelo Pielsa gearbeitet hat. Er hat in Lens eine sehr starke Methode entwickelt, um diese Physis immer wieder auf den Platz zu bringen. Es ist wirklich beeindruckend, welche Konstanzen die dabei an den Tag legen. Da sind sie dann auch oftmals einfach nicht zu stoppen. Man hat noch kein adäquates Mittel gefunden, um gegen dieses unfassbar offensive, schnelle Pressing um den Ball zu kommen. Am 6. März sehen wir, wie das dann gegen Marseille ausschaut. Ich meine, Marseille ist eine sehr stabile Mannschaft. Sie war letztes Jahr auch zweiter und muss jetzt eben schauen, dass man die Loans-Wa auf Abstand hält. Es wird schwierig genug, aber Loans hat auch in den letzten beiden Jahren die gute Ausgangsposition immer erst am Ende verspielt. Das heißt, jetzt geht es eigentlich erst ans Eingemachte. Ich glaube, das Spiel wird dann auch entscheiden gegen Marseille, auf jeden Fall.
Das ist ja verrückt, dass wir über den Erfolg eines Teams sprechen und dann landen wir nicht beim Trainer, nicht beim Sportdirektor, sondern beim Leistungsdiagnostiker und sagen, das ist der entscheidende Mann.
Kevin Danso, Ex-Augsburger, hat alle Spiele über 90 Minuten gemacht, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht ganz irre. Das sind viele Faktoren, aber der Leistungsdiagnostiker ist einer der wichtigsten Faktoren.
Da würde mich jetzt die anderen beiden interessieren. Marius, Fabian, da würde ich euch gerne mit reinholen. Wenn wir jetzt sagen, L'Anse ist das Team, das mit so einem offensiven Pressing, mit viel Laufarbeit, mit sehr viel Physik schafft, bis auf vielleicht sogar Platz 2 zu kommen. Wer ist in euren Ligen das Team, was dann vielleicht mit L'Anse am besten zu vergleichen wäre? Welchen mutmaßlich spanischen und italienischen Leistungsdiagnostiknamen muss ich mir bald drauf schaffen? Fabian, wer ist der Dauerläufer in La Liga?
Von der Spielweise würde ich jetzt zwar nicht ganz konform gehen, aber ich denke, Real Sociedad San Sebastian macht das richtig gut. Ich glaube, es ist nach wie vor Tabellen Vierter. Diese Positionen haben sie eigentlich fast die ganze Saison über und sind sehr konstant dort und stehen kurz vor dem Erreichen der Champions League dieses Jahr.
Das hast du doch jetzt absichtlich gemacht, Fabian. Wir werden nämlich gleich noch über Real Sociedad sprechen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber vorher muss ich natürlich Maius noch mit reinhören. Maius, wer ist der Dauerläufer in Serie A?
Die Werte habe ich jetzt nicht vorliegen, aber eigentlich ganz klassisch wäre das sicherlich Atalanta, die ja auch immer so ein recht krasses Offensivpressing auf jeden Fall seit Jahren etabliert haben. Und jetzt damit ja auch, auch wenn es nicht ganz so gut läuft wie in den letzten Jahren, ja doch mit 52 Punkten und vier Rückstand auf die Champions League-Plätze ziemlich gut dastehen.
Das stimmt. Aber geiles Spiel gegen die Roma am Montag war das 3 zu 1. Wobei auch wieder so ein bisschen ganz, ganz vintage Atalanta, mit sieben Schüssen drei Tore. Aber gefühlt waren sie halt viel überlegender. Man hatte halt gar nicht so mitbekommen, dass sie sich gar nicht so viele Chancen herausgespielt haben. Aber das war ein schöner Fight zwischen den beiden, habe ich sehr gerne nebenher laufen lassen, während ich Buchhaltung, glaube ich, gemacht habe. Na ja, werde Rasenfunk-Supporter, kann ich an der Stelle nur sagen. Okay, aber jetzt, bevor jetzt La Liga-Fans hier enttäuscht aufhören, warum wir so lange nicht über San Sebastian sprechen. Fabian, deine Bühne, du darfst uns jetzt erklären, warum Real Sociedad das nicht verspielen wird, diesen Champions League-Platz, den man jetzt noch hat. Sechs Punkte Vorsprung sind es und du sagst es ja schon. Im Grunde hätten wir schon immer mal wieder über sie sprechen können. Mein persönlicher Eindruck war immer, naja, die werden halt noch irgendwann da abgefangen und dann ist halt diese schöne Geschichte vorbei. Jetzt sieht es ja nicht mehr ganz so aus. Klar, es sind noch sieben Spiele für Real Sociedad, aber die sechs Punkte Vorsprung sind jetzt nicht so schlecht.
Die sind nicht so schlecht. Jetzt haben sie jetzt in der englischen Woche am Dienstag mit 0 zu 0 bei Betis, Sevilla, zumindest den direkten Verfolger erstmal auf Distanz gehalten. Ja, und ich denke, das Erfolgsrezept bei den Baskens ist einfach hauptsächlich tatsächlich der Trainer, der selber Spieler war bei San Sebastian, der dann die zweite Mannschaft trainiert hat, auch die Jugend trainiert hat und jetzt seit ein paar Jahren die erste Mannschaft trainiert, der Real Sociedad lebt, der Real Sociedad ist. Und die haben ein sehr stimmiges Verhältnis im Moment natürlich auch mit der Vereinsführung. Und ich finde besonders beachtlich dieses Jahr ist, dass sie ja am Anfang des Saison richtig, richtig, richtig großes Pech hatten. Also es hat mit Glück begonnen, denn sie haben ja Alexander Isak verkauft für sage und schreibe, glaube ich, 70 Millionen Euro an die Neureichen aus Newcastle United. Grüße an Uli. Und der macht das da auch richtig gut. Aber Real Sociedad hatte dann natürlich plötzlich kurz vor Transferende im Sommer keinen Stürmer mehr bzw. keinen gesetzten Neuner mehr. Und dann haben sie sich mit Umar Sadik einen geholt von Uri Almeria, von einem Aufsteiger, der in der zweiten Liga schon gebombt hat, ohne Ende der nigerianische Nationalspieler ist und der einfach eins der großen Stürmertalente in Europas ist oder war. Denn er war kaum mal eine Woche in St. Sebastian, da hat er sich das Kreuzband gerissen und dann war diese Reinvestition schon wieder dahin und ja, St. Sebastian hat ja noch ganz schnell am Transfermarkt geguckt, was noch zu machen ist und haben sich dann Alexander Sorlot von Leipzig noch schnell geschnappt und der ist jetzt im Moment der gesetzte Neuner und da sind wir ja eigentlich schon bei einem Punkt, wo man sagen muss, okay, der ist jetzt nicht vergleichbar mit den anderen beiden. Der macht das gut, der macht auch seine Tore, der macht seine Ablagen, hat natürlich körperlich auch einiges zu bieten, aber mehr ist nicht dieser Torgarant, dass die anderen beiden wahrscheinlich gewesen wären. Und dann hatten sie mit Miquel Ollarsaval, spanischer Nationalspieler, Kapitän von Real Sociedad, auch schon einen derben Ausfall, der auch mit Kreuzbondres ausgefallen ist, der vor ein paar Wochen erst zurückkam, natürlich noch weit weg ist von seiner Top-Leistung oder seinem Leistungs-Höhepunkt, sagen wir mal. Und auch diesen Rückschlag konnten sie verkraften, vereint wegstecken und sind einfach sehr, sehr konstant. Und haben da eine richtig gute Mischung gefunden, haben viele Jugendspiele auch hochgezogen und haben, wie gesagt, einen Trainer, der den Verein lebt jeden Tag. Das ist übrigens der Trainer, vielleicht können sich einige noch erinnern, der, glaube ich, letztes Jahr in der Europa-League-Saison die Vereinshymne einfach mal in der Pressekonferenz ins Mikrofon gebrüllt hat. Und zwar von vorne bis hinten über zwei Minuten oder so. Das ist richtig sympathisch, was da läuft, richtig groß, richtig gute Arbeit. Und die haben sich im Moment als stabilstes Team platziert, nach den großen drei in Spanien.
Immanuel Alguacil ist der Name, den sollten wir jetzt zumindest einmal noch fallen lassen, auch wenn ich Angst habe, ihn falsch ausgesprochen zu haben. Wenn du das jetzt so alles erzählst, also die Namen, das ist ja interessant eben genauso, das mit Ishak haben ja vielleicht noch einige mitbekommen, vielleicht auch noch die Leihe von Zürich. Aber dieses Wegstecken der Rückschläge scheint auch auf einer guten Defensive zu basieren. Also man hat 29 Tore jetzt kassiert in 31 Toren. Damit ist man jetzt nicht, also das ist durchaus nicht so untypisch für La Liga. Das ist was, was mir jetzt schon seit ein paar Wochen aufgefallen ist. Das ist eine ganze Reihe von sehr defensiv starken Teams gibt aktuell. Also wenn ich mir zum Beispiel angucke, wie Real Bilbao. Die haben auch nur 30 Gegentore kassiert. Gut, mit Barca will ich jetzt nicht anfangen, mit Atletico auch nicht. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so untypisch, auch Real Betis, gegen die man jetzt ja gerade unentschieden gespielt hat, nur 33. Aber dennoch diese Konstanz über die ganze Saison hinweg. Was zeichnet denn spielerisch San Sebastian aus?
Also sie haben vorne auf jeden Fall schon auch ein paar nette Spieler, die ja für Momentum so an können. Da ist zum Beispiel noch David Silva, der ja mal wieder seinen dritten, vierten Frühling oder so erlebt. Und ja, sie können sich da wirklich sehr, sehr gut ergänzen. Und was du gerade schon angesprochen hast, richtig, wie ich finde, mit der starken Defensivleistung, was deine Frage von vorher auch nochmal widerspiegelt. Es gibt jetzt kein so ein großes Team, das so ein Hauruck-Pressing macht. Vielleicht noch Rayo Valle Cano von Anone Idaola, aber die stehen ja auch weiter unten in der Tabelle. Also die Spanischen Liga oder die besten Teams der Spanischen Liga zeichnen sich eigentlich dieses Jahr mehr durch eine gewisse Ausgeglichenheit aus, was die Offensive und Defensive anbelangt. Und ja, Real Sociedad, wie gesagt, macht das sehr konstant und sehr gut und hat natürlich auch seit Emanol Alguacil dort Trainer ist, sehr viel Ruhe und sehr viel, ja, ich glaube Ruhe ist vielleicht das beste Wort. Die können da in Ruhe arbeiten, die haben die komplette Region hinter sich, natürlich auch der Vorstand und so weiter. Da gibt es keine Strohfeuer, keine Aufgeglichtheiten, kein Hollywood, kein gar nichts. Und so kann man gut arbeiten.
Ja, dann werden wir mal gucken, wie das ausgeht. Man spielt noch gegen Real, Barca und Atletico. Das sind noch weitere Gegner, die kommen, aber man hat eben auch die aktuell 6, beziehungsweise sollte Real noch ein weiteres Spiel gewinnen. Die liegen noch eins hinter, 5 Punkte Vorsprung hat man. Und dann könnte man es vielleicht bis in die Champions League schaffen. In dieser Saison ging es ja in der Europa League bis ins Achtelfinale. Da ist man dann gegen die Roma ausgeschieden mit 0 zu 2 und 0 zu 0. Dann springen wir noch einmal nach Italien und wollen uns mit dem Abstiegskampf befassen. Da hat sich wieder was getan. Hellas ist da ein bisschen am Tumulte verursacht. Ich glaube auch bei so manchen Konkurrenten. Wie sieht das da unten aus?
Hellas hat sich mit – lasst mich nochmal kurz gucken – zwei Siegen und einem Unentschieden aus den letzten drei Spielen den Anschluss hergestellt. Ich glaube, als ich letztes Mal hier zu Gast war, hatten Sie noch so gefühlt zehn Punkte Rückstand auf das rettende Ufer. Jetzt eben mit einer guten Phase und auch tatsächlich muss man sagen viel Spielglück, das im anderen Momenten der Saison vielleicht ein bisschen gefehlt hat. Kann man dann vielleicht sagen, das gleicht sich dann ja doch am Ende bis in einer Saison alles wieder aus. Haben Sie jetzt so das Momentum so ein bisschen auf Ihrer Seite, während es für Lecce und Spezia auf den letzten 16 und 17 mit 28 und 27 Punkten derzeit gar nicht mehr so rund läuft? Sie sind dann so ein bisschen auch – sie verlieren zwar nicht immer, aber sind trotzdem so ein bisschen in so einem Negativstrudel geraten. Und Hellas hat halt eben die Chance genutzt und ja, den Anschluss hergestellt und kann jetzt die Spiele am Sonntag beim schon fast sicheren Absteiger aus Kremonese oder eigentlich sicheren Absteiger aus Kremonese. Und Spezia spielt gegen Monster, die sehr stark sind, also für die Verhältnisse eines Aufsteigers. Und Bletsche spielt gegen Udinese auch ein supersolides Team. Also da kann man auf jeden Fall keinen Sieg irgendwie einplanen. Und ja, dann könnte es durchaus sein, dass Hellas eben die Abstiegsrenge verlässt und das zum ersten Mal seit dem siebten Spieltag.
Und gibt es neben den Ergebnissen und vielleicht auch etwas Spielglück auch noch andere Gründe? Also der wievielte Trainer sitzt da auf der Trainerbank. In der Bundesliga wäre es ja schon wahrscheinlich der vierte oder fünfte vielleicht sogar schon. Oder ja, wie ist da sonst die Situation jetzt?
Also seit Dezember ist ein eigentlich relativ unbekannter Trainer in den, so aus den ersten Ligen bei Hellas im Amt. Das ist Marco Zaffaroni, der hat nämlich vorher, bevor er dieses Amt bekommen hat, gar keine Serie A Erfahrung gehabt. Er ist quasi dem dem vorigen U19-Trainer Buketti an die Seite gestellt worden. Auch so ein bisschen aus Lizenzgründen. Und eigentlich sollte der das übernehmen, aber hatte dann noch nicht die richtigen Papiere. Und deswegen haben sie ihm halt einen erfahrenen Mann an die Seite gestellt. Und dieses Duo funktioniert eigentlich ziemlich gut. Es gab zwar zwischendurch auch eine Phase, wo sie nicht gewonnen haben, aber auch zum Jahresbeginn hatten sie auch mal vier Spiele nicht verloren. Und die beiden haben das geschafft, die Mannschaft auf jeden Fall defensiv sehr zu stabilisieren. Und vor allem diesen Kampfgeist, den die Mannschaft in den vergangenen Jahren unter Igor Tudor und Ivan Juric – das hat die so richtig ausgezeichnet – und das haben die irgendwie geschafft, wieder zurückzuholen. Also Hellas spielt nicht wirklich ansehentlichen Fußball, aber ist hinten ziemlich massiert, sage ich jetzt mal, und schafft es, effektiv zu kontern. Und ja, eben auch die Chancen, die sie haben, in Tore umzumünzen. Und dadurch eben so ein bisschen dieses angesprochene Momentum auf ihre Seite zu bekommen. Also die finde ich schon, dass es auch kadertechnisch durchaus stärker sind als die Konkurrenz da unten. Wenn man sich einen Linksverteidiger, Josh Stoick, anguckt, der zwar erst 20 ist, aber sicherlich im kommenden Sommer ein Kandidat ist, der für mehrere Millionen in die Premier League wechseln könnte, Faraoni oder Tameze, die auch unter Juric und Trudo schon sehr, sehr stark waren. Miguel Veloso, der Kapitän Portugiese, kennt man vielleicht noch. Und Simone Verdi, der jetzt auch gegen Bologna beim Sieg den Doppelpack gemacht hat. Das sind Spieler, die Qualität haben und auch im Abstiegskampf auf jeden Fall schon erfahren sind. Und was vielleicht ein bisschen Vorteile bringt gegenüber Mannschaften wie Spezia und Lecce, die zwar auch teilweise gute Spieler haben, aber in diesen Situationen eben noch nicht so oft waren, wie das teilweise diese sehr erfahrenen Spieler eben gewesen sind.
Und man hat ja auch noch ein interessantes Restprogramm, wenn ich mir das so angucke. Also jetzt Cremonese hast du schon angesprochen. Man spielt auch noch auswärts in Lecce oder bei Lecce, besser gesagt. Und noch zu Hause gegen Empoli am vorletzten Spieltag sollte man es eng halten mit den anderen da vorne. Also Empoli ist schon ein bisschen weg, könnte aber auch dementsprechend sein, dass es für die dann um nichts mehr geht an diesem vorletzten Spieltag. Dann könnte das da wirklich noch mal interessant werden.
Und das im 120. Jahr des Bestehens, also vor ein paar Wochen ist da erst die Feier ausgetragen worden, wo auch zum Beispiel die Meistermannschaft um Hans-Peter Briegel geehrt wurde. Also da will man ja dann ungern absteigen.
Da will man ungern absteigen, aber das habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt als Grundwissen vorausgesetzt, dass alle Leute sagen, na klar, Hellas, das ist ja gerade 120-jähriges Bestehen. Wer hätte das nicht jetzt schon direkt aufs Sättel gehabt? Aber gut, auch das Offensichtliche muss hier manchmal noch mal ausgesprochen werden in der Ligatur. Und wir wollen auch noch mal nach Frankreich blicken und uns mit Lille auseinandersetzen. Die liegen auf Rang 5. Und bei Lille, da über die haben wir schon mehrfach gesprochen, es ging immer so ein bisschen hin und her. Aber wenn ich das so richtig im Blick habe, Michael, ist man eigentlich in der Tabelle immer so relativ konstant in ungefähr dem Bereich, in dem man jetzt auch liegt. Was ist denn die aktuelle Situation? Was macht es notwendig, dass wir über Lille sprechen?
Eigentlich die Konstanz, die Lille überraschenderweise an den Tag legt. Ich meine, letztes Jahr war man Zehntemann, musste nach der Meisterschaft, die man mit dem jetzigen PSG-Trainer Christoph Kaltier da gewonnen hat, eine neue Mannschaft aufbauen. Man musste zeigen, dass man zu Recht da oben stand, hat man nicht geschafft und war dann eben im grauen Mittelfeld. Und da wieder rauszukommen, ist eben die Leistung, die man gönnen muss, weil man eben um Spieler wie den öfter genannten Jonathan David, der jetzt mit 21 Toren knapp hinter Kilian Mbappé, der Torschützenliste, steht, mit einem José Fonch, der dieser Turm in der Abwehr ist, und mit einem umfunktionierten Timothy Ware, der mal im Sturm spielt, mal auf den Außen, mal in der Verteidigung.
Auch in der Verteidigung?
Der hat auch mal Außenverteidiger gespielt. Das ist ein sehr polyvalenter Spieler, der sich damit natürlich auch auf die Zettel, die viele europäische Clubs gespielt hat, soll unter anderem auch Interesse aus der Bundesliga geben, zum Beispiel Gladbach, aber natürlich auch wegen seiner Herkunft, einer amerikanischen Wurzel, und Marseille ist interessiert. Da ist es jetzt die Frage, bleibt man auf den vorderen Plätzen? Du hast es gesagt, es ist Lille fünfter, drei Punkte vor Rennes, aber Rennes ist eine starke Mannschaft. Auch Lyon könnte theoretisch noch ein Wörtchen mitreden, auch wenn es nur noch sechs Partien zu spielen sind. Aber da muss man gefeiert sein, man muss diese Angriffe von denen abwehren und es geht noch gegen Monaco und Marseille. Es kommt jetzt ganz viel auf diesen Endspurt an und da ist dann auch die Frage, wie es in Zukunft läuft. Jonathan David steht bei vielen Top-Clubs in der Premier League auch auf dem Zettel. Sogar Bayern soll mal angefragt haben und da dann schon wieder eine neue Mannschaft aufzubauen, ist genau die Problematik, die sich dann auftun würde, vor allem, wenn man dann international spielt, in dem Fall in der Europa League.
Ist denn Jonathan David auch the real deal? Also klar, wenn jemand irgendwie nur ein Tor hinter Killian Mbappé in der Torjägerliste legt, ich glaube 25 Torbeteilungen in 31 Spielen, hat er gesagt, das ist alles sehr gut. Könnte ja aber auch so ein One-Hit-One-Season-Wonder sein.
Ja, das ist er definitiv nicht. Also nach den letzten beiden Saisons, wo er auch schon geknipst hat, es war natürlich mal die Gefahr, er ist ja auch noch jung, dass er da abbaut. Er war zuvor ein bisschen im Schatten von Burak Yilmaz, der war da aber schon 35, 36 und ist dann gegangen. Und dann ist David eben der Nachfolger von dem vorhin erwähnten Victor Simeon geworden und hat regelmäßig sogar in der letzten Saison seine Tore gemacht, was schon von einer gewissen Konstanz zeugt, was aber natürlich in der Liga A auch noch mal eine andere Nummer ist als in der Premier League und darin besteht dann genau die Aufgabe, auch bei einem anderen Verein, auch in einer anderen Liga, die dann deutlich physischer verteidigt, seine Qualitäten nachzuweisen. Auch bei der WM war er ja dabei, hat es nicht groß in Erscheinung getreten, was dann natürlich auch daran liegt, dass das ganze kanadische Team keinen großen Auftrag hatte und ja, also ein One-Hit-Wanderer ist er nicht. Ich glaube, dass er, wenn er in der Liga A bleibt, weiter knipsen wird. Die Frage ist, ob das auch in der Premier League oder woanders möglich ist, die Qualität dazu hat er aber auf jeden Fall.
Und er spielt natürlich auch in einem offensiv starken Team, also Paolo von Zecca, der ja von der Roma gekommen ist, ist da der Trainer. Und wenn ich mir zum Beispiel die Expected Goals angucke, dann liegt Lille sogar auf Rang 2 hinter PSG. Es gibt eine Lücke, aber die ist gar nicht so groß. In den Toren, die man erzielt hat, ist es tatsächlich ein bisschen anders. Da hat Monaco ein bisschen mehr erzielt. Aber das liest sich für mich, ohne dass ich jetzt viel von Lille gesehen hatte. So ehrlich muss ich sein, als würde man eben auch einen Offensivfußball spielen.
Das tut man auf jeden Fall. Das Spiel ist natürlich auch auf Jonathan David ausgelegt. Man weiß, dass er schnell ist. Man weiß, dass er unglaublich viel arbeiten kann und Bälle verteilen, aber auch ins Tor schießen kann. Er hat eine Vielseitigkeit, die er sich in den letzten Jahren antrainiert hat. In seiner Jugend wurde er in Salzburg und in Stuttgart angeboten. Er konnte wegen Visa-Problemen nicht wahrnehmen, aber er hat damals schon immer Extra-Schichten geschoben. Er hat das auch weiterverfolgt, als er nach Europa gekommen ist. Diese Vielseitigkeit zeichnet ihn dann aus. Du sagst Expected Goals, klar, aber die Tore muss man dann eben auch machen. Er hat diese Kalt-Schneuzigkeit. Es ist ein offensives Team, klar. Es ist ein Team, das ihm die Bälle zuspielt, aber er erarbeitet die Tore.
Okay, also wir sehen, da gibt es definitiv ein Stürmer-Talent, das vielleicht wieder aus der Liga A kommen würde. Wer ja jetzt nicht das erste, wer nicht das erste, was einen dann überrascht. Wir werden verfolgen, ob Lil das schaffen kann, sich da oben zu halten. Wie gesagt, die Voraussetzungen sind dafür da. Danke dir, Michael. Und dann habe ich an euch alle drei nur noch eine letzte Frage, die auch Uli gleich noch beantworten werden muss, nämlich, welche Spiele sollte man am Wochenende unbedingt im Blick haben bei euch in der Liga? Fabian, du darfst mal beginnen. In La Liga gibt es ein Aufeinandertreffen. Gibt es da so ein Was macht Ossasuna? Müssen wir uns mit Firona gegen Cattiz? Was ist da los? Was kannst du uns anbieten?
Na, es ist heiß in der Liga, was die europäischen Plätze anbelangt. Von daher gibt es ein interessantes Duell bereits am heutigen Abend, nämlich Athletic Bilbao spielt zu Hause gegen Sevilla. Das sind vielleicht die zwei Teams, die im Moment am meisten in Form sind. Ich glaube, Bilbao hat jetzt drei Spiele in Folge gewonnen und meldet sich nochmal an im Kampf um Europa. Und Sevilla hat sich mit dem neuen Trainer Mendy Lieber befreit und ist jetzt auf Platz 13 hochgerutscht. Da kann man am heutigen Abend schon mal gar nichts falsch machen. Das ist jetzt erstmal das Spiel von heute Abend.
Das ist ein bisschen enger, als ich das zuletzt so in Erinnerung hatte.
Ich bin gespannt, was Bettys macht, weil sie gerade einen Einbruch unter Pellegrini haben. Sie waren lange Zeit für mich das Team, das vielleicht die Champions League noch packen kann. Jetzt sind sie sechs Punkte hinten. Aber wir haben natürlich noch ein paar Spieltage, sieben Spieltage glaube ich noch. Also von daher darf man die nicht abschreien. Wir real mit Kike Sedien ist immer ein interessantes Team. Wie gesagt, Bilbao gerade wirklich in Form, mit drei Siegen in Folge. Die Basken werden auch nochmal angreifen. Osasuna und Valle Cano würde ich jetzt da ein bisschen ausnehmen. Ich glaube, die werden es nicht nach oben noch reinschaffen. Aber genau, zwischen Real Sociedad, die es wahrscheinlich in der Champions League schaffen und dann Betis wie Real und Athletic. Da wird es spannend bleiben.
Das kann man sich auf jeden Fall angucken und ist natürlich völlig klar, warum ich nach Girona gefragt habe. Denn da spielt Valentin Castellanos, der alleine Real Madrid mit 4 zu 2 abgeschossen hat. So muss man es sagen. Er hat vier seiner elften Sortore gegen Real gemacht. Der hatte einen richtig guten Abend. Wann war das? Am Dienstag, glaube ich. Ja, also da ging es gut ab. Gibt es noch weitere Spiele? Deswegen dieser kleine Girona-Gag, den ich da unbedingt noch mit einbauen würde. Gibt es noch weitere Partie, auf die man blicken sollte?
Man hat am Wochenende, auf jeden Fall Samstagabend, ein nettes Spiel mit Barcelona gegen Betis. Beide gerade zwar nicht in Top-Form, aber ich denke, vom Namen her kann man sich das schon mal antun. Alle anderen Partien versprechen jetzt am ersten Blick vielleicht nicht so viel. Kann immer passieren. Girona ist ja so ein Manchester City-Ausbildungs-Satelliten-Club. Castellanos, den du angesprochen hast, war ja früher bei New York City zu Girona. Wahrscheinlich kommt er dann in zwei Jahren zu Manchester City, wenn er so weitermacht wie bisher.
Na, das ist doch schön, dass Manchester auch endlich mal wieder ein bisschen Talent in sein Team bekommt. Das können Sie gebrauchen. Das ist die gute News zum Donnerstagvormittag. Dann schauen wir noch auf die Serie A. Marius, was sollten wir denn in Italien im Blick behalten?
Es ist das römische, meiländische Wochenende und damit ja auch der absolute Kampf um die Champions League-Plätze. Am Samstag um 18 Uhr empfängt Jose Mourinhos Roma Milan. Die sind ja beide bei 56 Punkten und haben tatsächlich auch die gleiche Tor-Differenz. Da geht es auf jeden Fall um viel. Festung Olympico wird sicherlich auch ziemlich stimmungsvoll werden. Am Sonntag um 12.30 Uhr empfängt Inter Lazio. Sollte Lazio dieses Spiel nicht gewinnen und zeitgleich am Tag davor Napoli Salenitana schlagen, dann stehen sie dann eben auch vom Sofa her als Meister fest. Da gab es noch Gespräche, ob man das nicht zeitgleich stattfinden lassen soll. Das wollte ich gerade sagen. Das ist aber, glaube ich, noch nicht entschieden. Das ist, glaube ich, noch nicht entschieden.
Ach so, das weiß man jetzt noch nicht. Am Donnerstag, ob am Samstag oder am Donnerstag. Okay, da muss wieder von Olympische Komitee wahrscheinlich zu sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt in Deutschland, da wäre jetzt noch nicht mal der Antrag durch. Deswegen dieses Italien-Bashing, glaube ich, möchte ich da nicht haben.
Ich sehe das eher so aus romantischer Sicht.
Ja, das wäre schon das, was ich jetzt auch sagen wollte. Also Napoli könnte wieder Meister werden und dann, ich meine, auf dem Sofa säße dann keiner. Da könnten wir uns da schon sicher sein, sitzen würde da auch keiner. Aber schöner wäre es natürlich tatsächlich, wenn das in einem Stadion passieren könnte.
Genau, eben deshalb. Das ist das Ding, ja.
Gut, vielleicht wird ja das Spiel noch verschoben. Dann bekämen wir da unseren Wunsch. Und dann haben wir ja noch die Ligue 1. Michael, auf was sollten wir da achten an diesem Wochenende?
Ja, am ersten, Straßburg gegen Lyon. Straßburg ist noch akut abstiegsgefährdet. Lyon möchte noch um jeden Preis die internationalen Plätze erreichen. Und wenn ich außerhalb der Liga irgendwas sagen dürfte, dann ist natürlich am Samstag, finde das Pokalfinale statt, zwischen Toulouse und Nantes. Zwei, die es in der Liga nicht immer gezeigt haben, aber Nantes kann den Pokalsieg wiederholen. Ist auch, ebenso wie Straßburg, akut abstiegsgefährdet. Immer noch liegt nur knapp über dem Strich, mit zwei oder drei Torenvorsprung nur vor Brest. Also man kann sich am Freitag die Liga anschauen, dann Straßburg gegen Lyon und dann am Samstag das Pokalfinale Toulouse gegen Nantes.
Ja, und ich habe irgendwie so das Gefühl, über diesen Abstiegskampf werden wir noch sprechen. Augère, Straßburg, Nantes und Brest innerhalb von zwei Punkten. Also die einen haben 33, Augère und die anderen haben 32. Da ist es nur die Tordifferenz und die ist minimal unterschiedlich. Minus 10, minus 11, minus 13. Ich habe das Gefühl, über den Abstiegskampf in der Liga 1 werden wir noch sprechen. Denn das PSG Meister wird irgendwann, das muss dann nicht mehr so wirklich thematisiert werden. Ich danke euch dreien sehr. Herzlichen Dank an Michael Postel vom Kicker. Danke, dass du wieder mit dabei warst.
Dankeschön auch, Max.
Danke an Marius Seucke, der M. Seucke auf Twitter. Habe ich vorhin, glaube ich, gar nicht gesagt. Danke, Marius. Und ich danke auch dem Ed Rosengartler, Fabian Pacula. Danke dir, lieber Fabian. Grüße nach Spanien. Und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit Uli Hebel. Jetzt begrüße ich Uli Hebel bei mir, die Stimme von Sky und der Saunen und natürlich auch von Click and Rush, dem Premier League Podcast. Hallo Uli.
Hallo, grüß dich.
Schön, dass du hier bist. Wir haben es hinter uns, das große Spiel der Saison. Wir alle haben darauf gewartet. City gegen Arsenal. Die Frage, würde Arsenal irgendwie es doch schaffen, gegen diese Übermacht aus Manchester zu bestehen? Man muss sagen, nein. 1 zu 4, das war dann sehr deutlich schon in der siebten Minute Kevin De Bruyne. John Stoens dann noch ganz kurz vor der Halbzeit und als dann das 3 zu 0 gefallen ist. Wieder durch Kevin De Bruyne in der 54. Minute nach Vorlage von Eiling Haarland. Da war der Car's Gessen 4 zu 1 am Ende gewinnt City, hat jetzt zwei Punkte Rückstand, aber ja auch noch zwei Spiele weniger. Der Drops ist gelutscht, oder? Das wird sich jetzt City nicht mehr nehmen lassen.
Jetzt muss ich aufpassen, was ich antworte. Ich sage in unserem Podcast immer, ich falle nicht mehr um und da wird immer die Prozentfrage gestellt, zu wie viel Prozent ist die Möglichkeit da, dass Arsenal Meister wird und ich habe gesagt, ich gehe nie unter 51. Aber ich mache eine fette Null vor die 51 und ein Komma. Weil ja, also ich glaube leider, das war's. Also ich fürchte, das hat man ja in dem Spiel auch gesehen, wo der Unterschied noch liegt, kann ich mir schwer vorstellen, dass es irgendwas gibt, was in irgendeiner Weise Arsenal jetzt doch noch nach vorne schiebt. Ich glaube aber, ehrlich gesagt, auch selbst hätten die aus irgendwelchen Gründen Mittwochabend gewonnen, hätte ich trotzdem inzwischen fast auf City getippt, weil es einfach zu deutlich aussieht im Moment.
Ja, diese drei Unentschieden von Arsenal, die haben halt wirklich rein gefressen, jetzt die drei Unentschieden, die man jetzt zuletzt hatte vor diesem Spiel. Also quasi der Einbruch kam eigentlich schon vorher. 2-2 gegen Liverpool, das war ja eher noch glücklich und gut da einen Punkt mitzunehmen. 2-2 gegen West Ham und dann dieses 3-3 gegen Southampton. Auch da irgendwie auch noch gut da trotzdem einen Punkt mitzunehmen. Aber es reicht halt nicht und wenn du dann so deutlich verlierst, sagt es was deiner Meinung nach auch aus über den Zustand der Liga, dass es dann, naja, wir hatten jetzt eben diesen Sondereffekt, Arsenal. Aber letztlich läuft ja jetzt dann doch wieder auf das hinaus, was wir auch vor der Saison im Grunde so erwarten konnten.
Ja, ich würde gar nicht sagen, dass es an der Liga liegt als solches. Denn es sagt viel über Manchester City aus. Und wenn du mir die Ausfahrt einmal erlaubst, ich habe das auch schon in sozialen Netzwerken so gesagt. Und dazu stehe ich aber auch. Ich finde trotzdem, egal wie die Saison ausgeht für Arsenal, und ich prognostiziere mal, dass es jetzt eine plus zehn Punkte Saison wird für City am Ende, ist es trotzdem eine total besondere Truppe, die Arsenal da hat. Und sie sind so weit voraus dem Prozess, dass es überhaupt kein Beinbruch ist, dass das jetzt so läuft, wie es läuft. Die Diskrepanz in diesem Spitzenspiel zwischen dem, was angekündigt war und dem, was letztlich auf dem Feld zu sehen war, war wahrscheinlich nie größer in einem Topspiel, in einem Saison-definierenden Spiel. Und trotzdem ist Arsenal im Schnitt, sind die Leistungsträger 22, 23 Jahre alt. Diese Truppe hat zusammen noch nie ein Champions-League-Spiel absolviert. Das werden sie erst nächstes Jahr tun. Die haben einen Trainer, von dem ich denke, dass er so ziemlich für alles Lösungen findet, nur wenn – und das ist der große Unterschied von allen anderen Mannschaften im Vergleich zu Manchester City und so etwas muss aber auch wachsen – wenn bei Arsenal ein William Sadi Bar fehlt, dann kommt Rob Holding rein. Das ist gar kein persönlicher Vorwurf von Rob Holding, aber der ist einfach nicht gut genug. Und dann könnte man sich noch überlegen, naja, wäre jetzt Tommy Yasso gesund, dann könnte Ben White in die Mitte rutschen. Oder vielleicht auch mal auf die 6. Position, wo Thomas Pate eine Saison spielt, in der 25 Spiele lang sensationell war und jetzt 10 Spiele lang durchschnittlich bis hunsmiserabel war. Und das kann Arsenal einfach nicht problemlos auffangen. Und das Beispiel, das ich den nenne, ist Nathan Arkay. Das ist für mich zum Niederknien die Saison, die der spielt. Dessen Taglings sind grandios. Also wer Taglings mag, einfach mal bei YouTube reinhaken. Das ist italienischer 90er-Jahrestil von Nathan Arkay. Der fehlt gegen Arsenal und du musst nicht drüber reden. Weil es einfach überhaupt nicht ins Gewicht fällt, weil sie problemlos rumschieben können, wie sie lustig sind. Und einen qualitativ genauso guten, wenn nicht sogar teilweise passenderen oder besseren Ersatz finden. Und das ist bei Arsenal, das Wort ist wichtig, noch nicht der Fall. Ich glaube, das kann passieren, aber noch ist es nicht so.
Und dann könnte man das ja sogar auch als positives Zeichen sehen, auch wenn es jetzt wahrscheinlich mit der Meisterschaft nichts wird für Arsenal. Denn so ein bisschen stehen da ja auch so zwei verschiedene Ansätze, wie man ein Erfolgsteam zusammenstellt sich gegenüber. Also Manchester City mit… Also alles, was das financial Fairplay irgendwie austricksen kann, da muss man nicht viel Footballleaks gelesen haben, um das mitzubekommen, waren ja auch schon mal in der Champions League aus dem Wettbewerb genommen und dann wieder zurückgeklagt und so weiter und so fort. Unglaublich hohe Ausgaben für Transfers und so weiter. Und auf der anderen Seite eben ein Arsenal, das unter anderem am Trainer sehr lange festgehalten hat und ja so ein bisschen die Spieler bei sich versammelt hat. Also wenn ich mir zum Beispiel den Ödegard angucke oder auch Kranichaka kann man da glaube ich auch nennen, Cinchenko und so weiter. Also diejenigen, die zwar sehr, sehr leistungsstark sind, aber noch mal beweisen mussten, dass sie es auch wirklich auf allerhöchstem Level können.
Ja und ich wünsche mir ehrlich gesagt auch, dass sie es genauso beibehalten. Das ist die große Frage. Gehen sie jetzt nach dieser Saison her und sagen, okay, wir brauchen vielleicht zwei, drei total erfahrende Spieler zu holen, 30-Jährige oder machen sie diesen Weg auch miteinander? Also Sinchenko fällt ja insofern aus dem Raster, dass er bei Arsene jetzt ein bisschen älter ist. Chaka ist ja auch noch nicht alt, das ist ja immer noch alles im Rahmen. Gerade Chaka ist ja da gewesen, das war ja auch erstaunlich, weil sie den ja schon mehrfach abladen wollten, aber Ateta scheint eine tolle Beziehung zu ihm zu haben. Das ist aber natürlich einer, der jetzt auf Sicht irgendwann mal ausgetauscht werden muss, in der Mannschaft auch aus Qualitätsgründen, ohne ihm da jetzt zu nahe treten zu wollen. Da bin ich jetzt total gespannt, wie sie es machen. Ob sie jetzt denken, wir sind einen Schritt davon entfernt und los geht's, alles reingebuttert in die Truppe, oder ob sie bei sich bleiben und eben den organischen Prozess passieren lassen, so wie City damals gemacht hat. Und wenn sie das tun, das ist meine Prognose, dann sind sie in den nächsten Jahren mit dabei. Ob sie es irgendwann mal schaffen, die sind nicht so schlecht, die da vorne dranlaufen. Das ist wahrscheinlich somit das Beste, was Europa zu bieten hat an einem normalen Tag. Und die normalen Tage häufen sich wieder in den letzten Monaten. Aber dann haben wir ein Team, das zusätzlich dazu rutscht.
Wir werden es verfolgen, ob Arsene seinen Weg weitergeht. Ganz kurz wollen wir dann aber auch über die Spurs sprechen. Die gehen ihren Weg auch weiter, aber der hat viele Kurven, dieser Weg. Und irgendwie führt er zu nichts.
Ja, das tut mir total leid, dass ich immer mit Hotnam hier bei dir komme, weil es ist Wahnsinn. Wir nehmen ja noch vor dem Spiel gegen Manchester United auf. Es kann schon sein, dass es da noch mal eine Extra-Story gäbe, aber haben ihren Interimstrainer, der es bis Saisonende machen sollte, jetzt entlassen, nachdem sie bei Newcastle United 6-1 untergehen. Das waren die fürchterlichsten 21 Minuten eines Teams, die ich je gesehen habe. Vor allem noch gemessen an dem, was als Ziel ist. Das ist nach wie vor Champions-League-Qualifikation. Das war eine Offenbarung. Deswegen ist die Reaktion klar. Jetzt sind wir dabei. Wir haben es beim letzten Mal auch schon kurz besprochen, dass Fabio Paratienschi nicht mehr dabei ist, sportlicher Chef, weil der gesperrt wurde. Er hat ein paar Tage vorher noch ein Interview gegeben, dass alles gut wird. Ein paar Tage später ist die Sperre da. Er muss dann zurücktreten. Und jetzt ist Tottenhamen ohne Sportvorstand, ohne Trainer, ohne Plan, ohne Richtung, ohne funktionierendes Team hat dieser Mannschaft wahnsinnig viele Ausreden gegeben. Die Truppe wirkt ausgezerrt von vielen verschiedenen Trainer-Ideen. Also kurzum, das, was wir jetzt hier erleben, ist wahrscheinlich aufgerechnet das Problem der letzten 4 Jahre, in dem die Spurs aber auch nichts richtig gemacht haben. Vielleicht im Vakuum für sich jede einzelne Trainer-Entscheidung oder Sportvorstand oder wie auch immer Sportchef, wie man es nennen will, Entscheidung kann man nachvollziehen, aber zusammengerechnet ist es furchtbar, was da als Summe rauskommt.
Damit Tottenham auf Rang 7. Punkt gleich zwar noch mit Liverpool auf Rang 6, aber eben die zwei Niederlagen. Und jetzt eben das ausstehende Spiel gegen Manchester United wird wichtig. Und schon am nächsten Spieltag wird man sich direkt mit Liverpool auswärts duellieren. Da könnten die Reds dann wiederum ganz wichtigen Punkte gewinnen. Möglicherweise landen, aber wir wollen auch über positive Dinge sprechen. Uli, wir wollen uns hier nicht immer mit den Problemfällen befassen. Lass uns über Aston Villa sprechen. Was ist denn da eigentlich los? Sie liegen auf Rang 5, haben 54 Punkte. Damit sind sie noch nicht sicher durch und so weiter. Also das kann auch noch quasi vom Ergebnis her eine unbefriedigende Saison werden, weil man noch mal rausfliegt aus den europäischen Rängen. Aber wenn ich mir die letzten 2, 4, 6, 8, 10, 11 spiele, wenn ich mich gerade nicht verrechnet habe, ich habe nicht verrechnet, aber es waren auf jeden Fall sehr viele ungeschlagene Spiele. Man hat einen unheimlichen Lauf hingelegt. Wie ist das möglich?
Die Antwort ist Unai Emery. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Der kam ja nach England. Da haben wir damals auch drüber geredet hier mit England. Da sagt er mal an, Finish Business. Also damals noch bei Arsenal und er hat irgendwie das Gefühl, er muss noch was beweisen und das tut er gerade. Hat aus einer Mannschaft, die unter Steven Gerrard das langweiligste Team der Liga war, gar nichts. Ich wusste überhaupt nicht, was das sein soll. Ein Team gemacht, das jetzt immer noch nicht höchst attraktiv spielt. Aber die nutzen jetzt endlich Potenzial. Es ist gar nicht großartig anders, was sie spielen. Die sind wirklich wie so ein Chamäleon, passen sich immer dem Gegner an. Und das ist ja Una Emery's große Superkraft, dass er einfach den Matchplan des Gegenübers so ausrechnet, dass er sie dermaßen einfach runterzieht aufs Niveau, das sie brauchen, damit sie dann einfach ihr Spiel gewinnen können. So macht das meistens, wenn es klappt. Und das kommt dazu, dass so ziemlich jeder einzelne Spieler, der im Moment zumindest spielt, seine eigene Form verbessert hat, mit dem ganz anderen Selbstbewusstsein auftritt. Das haben auch Einzelne davon wie McGinn zum Beispiel mal gesagt, dass er von Unai Emery die so klare Anweisungen bekommt per Video, wie er es noch überhaupt nie bekommen hat. Und er weiß zu jedem Zeitpunkt, was er zu tun hat. Und das lässt sich im Moment einfach die Ergebnisse holen. Nochmal nicht immer gut spielen, aber die Ergebnisse holen. Und eine besondere Nennung muss noch erlaubt sein. Olly Watkins, von dem ich immer ziemlich viel gehalten habe, weil die Einstellung, die technischen Fähigkeiten und auch die grundsätzlich physischen Voraussetzungen so sind, dass das ein wahnsinnig guter Stürmer sein muss, an dem auch Arsenal zum Beispiel dran war. Und der ist, der dreht plötzlich hohl unter Unai Emery. Das ist der absolut klare Zielspieler. Das war er vorher nie, sondern er war eigentlich eher so ein Schattenstürmer, der für andere kreieren musste oder für Coutinho ablegen musste und eigentlich eher für zweite Bälle oder für Konter da war. Und jetzt ist er ein klarer Zielspieler geworden. Und man sieht plötzlich auch bei dem, ach guck mal, der ist ja gar nicht so schlecht.
Und wie wird das begleitet in den Medien und von vielleicht auch anderen Verantwortlichen? Also Emery war ja zwischendurch noch bei Viareal, das war quasi die Station nach Asne und jetzt eben diese Rückkehr, die ja zumindest dann jetzt ja wirklich beeindruckend ist.
Ja, also es ist so, dass intern immer ein großes Ziel ausgegeben worden ist. Also die Besitzer von Aston Villa sind sehr, sehr ambitionierte Leute, die unter anderem auch die Milwaukee Bucks haben in der NBA. Und die dachten mit Steven Gerrard diesen Schritt zu machen, dass sie näher rankommen an die europäischen Plätze, die mittelfristig das klare Ziel sind. Und entsprechend ist immer auch so ein bisschen Häme mitgeschwungen, als Steven Gerrard jetzt nicht so gut war. Und dann hat man automatisch immer das Narrativ aufgemacht, ach, die alten Weltklassik-Spieler England sind keine guten Trainer, Lampard und Gerrard. Und das ist auch wahr, vor allen Dingen bei Erstgenanntem. Und dann kam Una Emery und irgendwie so haben sich alle, glaube ich, etwas mehr Glamour erwartet bei der nächsten Trainerentscheidung Villas. Jetzt aber wird natürlich schon auch darüber gesprochen, wie gut der Typ das eigentlich gemacht hat. Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass es eher jetzt Emery von Villareal und Villa ist und der Arsenal Emery wird abgespaltet, über den man sich ja lustig gemacht hat. Muss man ja genauso sagen in seiner Zeit bei Arsenal. Und das hat er schon mal auf jeden Fall geholt, weil er zeigt, was er wirklich drauf hat als Trainer.
Und glaubst du, das bringt Villareal jetzt noch ins Ziel, dass man eben da auf Rang 5 oder 6 bleiben kann?
Also es ist wirklich schwierig. Also ich glaube nicht mehr, dass Brighton das packt, obwohl die mir grundsätzlich am besten gefallen. Aber das ist ein qualitatives Problem, glaube ich, bei denen, dass sie es einfach vom Spielermaterial her nicht haben. Tottenham ist bodenlos. Deswegen glaube ich eigentlich auch fast, dass die das gar nicht packen.
Ach so, dann wäre es ja schon erreicht.
Genau, und dann hast du es eigentlich schon. Und wahrscheinlich reicht ja Platz 7 auch.
Stimmt.
Ich kann mir das gut vorstellen, dass es reicht.
Richtig, den Rang 7, den habe ich jetzt gar nicht mit reingerechnet. Also das sieht da dann wirklich sehr gut aus für Aston Villa. Dann habe ich nur noch eine abschließende Frage an dich, Uli. Und zwar, welche Spiele müssen wir uns unbedingt angucken? Eins, das hast du jetzt schon genannt, das findet jetzt auch erst am heutigen Abend statt. Also wir nehmen am Donnerstag den 27. April auf. Wenn ihr schnell seid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann könnte euch die Spurs gegen United noch geben. Was gibt es denn darüber hinaus noch zu gucken?
Also es geht schon weiter Samstag, Sonntag und dann auch Montag. Ich glaube trotzdem, dass man Tottenham im Auge behalten muss, weil das ist so das Finale dann am Sonntag gegen Liverpool, bei Liverpool hast du ja schon mal kurz angesprochen. Ich glaube, das muss man gucken. Und worauf ich mich tatsächlich sehr freue ist, auch weil es so ein kleines Abstiegs-Endspiel auch ist. Ich glaube nämlich, dass das Team, das es gewinnt, durch ist. Crystal Palace am Samstag zur frühen Anschlusszeit gegen West Ham United. West Ham fehlt glaube ich noch ein Punkt oder ein Sieg. Das traue ich ihnen zu. Dann sind die durch. Und bei Crystal Palace soll es eigentlich schon reichen. Wenn sie es aber packen, dann sind auch die durch. Das sind gerade die Duellen, die vom Matchplanning her dankenswerterweise immer genauso hingehen, dass ganz oft solche Spiele sind, wo man dann weiß, ah okay, die sind raus, die kann ich abhaken. Das gefällt mir gerade ganz gut in der Premier League. Das ist natürlich Zufall, aber es ist schön, wie es fällt gerade.
Sehr, sehr gut. Also es geht langsam auf die entscheidende Phase zu. Auch hier in dieser Ligatur, bzw. hier ist dann die entscheidende Phase eigentlich schon vorbei, wenn man ehrlich ist. Denn jetzt möchte ich mich von dir verabschieden. Uli, du hast dich hier trotz gesundheitlich angeschlagener Stimme durchgepeitscht. Vielen, vielen Dank dir für deine Zeit. Et Uli Hebe, man kann dir überall folgen, wo es soziale Netzwerke gibt. Danke dir, dass du mit dabei warst in der Ligatur. Und dann auch nochmal herzlichen Dank an die vorherigen Gäste, Michael Postel, Marius Seuke und Fabian Pakulat. Das war Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 260. Bitte unterstützt den Rasenfunk finanziell, rasenfunk.de, supporters club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie das geht. Und auch unsere Gäste profitieren davon. Sie bekommen natürlich ein Gästehonorar. In diesem Sinne, bleibt gesund, bleibt den Rasenfunk gewogen und bitte empfehlt uns weiter, vor allem die Ligatour. Danke euch und bis bald, machts gut, ciao!